if you ask respectfully like if you're
the one you know listen to rock email
day times there's people who like
inappropriately stand outside my office
and do other things that's not gonna
work if you're making the person
uncomfortable if you're not bringing
them value but if you respectfully ask
yeah you're putting yourself in a
position everybody so we continue our
series of interviews here I can thank
you for everybody listening on the
podcast anybody watching on video it's
been a good start we're in daytime and
day 2 here and we continue the process
with a gentleman that I admire quite a
bit as most of you know I rarely have
individuals on my show that I'm actually
actively doing business with because I
always think it's a tough spot for them
it's a tough spot for me for the
audience but what I've noticed with the
last year or two when you go macro or
micro with it at the end of the day what
I'm most passionate about is educating
the audience giving them insights and
sometimes there's a huge advantage of
being up close and personal I've I've
seen this gentleman push the envelope in
the short period of time we've been in
the trenches we've known of each other
for a long time we've worked with Pepsi
Co with Mountain Dew with Pepsi in
different ways we're now very involved
at Pepsi blue key on Digital side and
this showman is at the helm Todd why
don't you tell the Vayner nation who you
are what your title is and then we'll
get into the show yeah sure I'm Todd
Kaplan I head up the Pepsi brand in
North America and and yeah and I've been
working at PepsiCo for a number of
different years and a variety of
different functions as you know we
rotate around in the market yeah I have
done everything from mountain dude
branded entertainment to sports to most
recently our water portfolio where I
would created and launched to do Brian's
life water and bubbly and then now on
this massive it's it's it's really more
it's exciting it's a lot of people watch
and listen to my content are
entrepreneurial but as my career's
evolved into the marketing landscape I
get way more DMS and emails and
linkedin's about hey I may want to run a
brand or you know I think you know this
personally when I talked about buying
morph and brands long term still work in
a mug root beer so we'll talk about that
off-camera you know people like hey I
want to do that or I want to be involved
how did that happen for you look let's
go all the way back we're reborn I'm
from Southern California
originally some I'm a West Coast guy
grew up in SoCal fish not a surfer kid
but I definitely grew up like a
skateboard working white I do sports I
played tennis I do
I'm not Orioles fan I'm definitely not
like I'm a huge Lakers fan I'm an angel
I know that girl
are you completely I got a deed okay you
got a moment alike we're just super bad
super pumped for that they didn't give
up the farm by the way but I think
they're a couple of free agents away
from a couple other pieces they need to
make coos - what you're kind of like
they kept coos they got a tea they got
bran and I think they need you know
someone on the point though do you think
Jimmy Butler's coming I've heard Butler
I've heard Kemba I've heard a variety of
things you know I don't know where when
you're excited I'm excited
at least that's your squad that's how
old are you make sure I'm 40
right so magic I don't have magic you're
a man then you know Shaq cook that's all
do like that shows it like basketballs
number one for you as far as viewing
yeah and then yeah basketball and then
I'd say you have any second favorite
team as the Angels angel and so I grew
up about like 15 minutes from Anaheim
Stadium and so you know growing up again
angels that was a bit of a tougher fans
yeah salmon was fun I could have sense
of anything Jeff and Knicks fan I mean
you literally couldn't write a script of
clay and dread getting hurt leading into
that I mean that whole it's gonna be
crazy what happened I feel bad for a the
Warriors beat I mean KD this was I mean
the Knicks fans that just blows up
everything so you grew up in SoCal
you're into those sports things what
else are you kind of about yes so I'm a
big student worried entrepreneurially
neither so entrepreneurial it's funny
you talk about that like yeah actually
and you probably don't even know any of
this stuff to know hiya
I have a very entrepreneurial neck as
well like that's actually one of the
reasons why I think as I look at now I
see your machines I see your creativity
yeah like you know like out of all the
people who work with like there's a
level of creativity that is obvious to
me which a lot of times I do associate
with entrepreneurship it doesn't stun me
go ahead but it's but it's not just
critic it's connecting it to just
getting [ __ ] done moving yeah making it
happen and so on entrepreneurial
so I've broken Southern California you
know good grades you know topically all
that kind of stuff but went to
Northwestern for undergrad which was an
interesting case you know going from you
know 80 degrees on the beach all the way
to like you know sub-zero temperatures
on Lake Michigan and Chicago weather
that end up happening you know I wanted
to go to a big school but not too big it
was like d1 it was like big 10 rah rah
but it's still a very good school yeah
that was around the time they'd been in
like the Rose Bowl Gary Barnett all that
class and so I'm like you know what I
think the Rose Bowl check that out it
was and it was great and it's a great
school and so reason and it was a mystic
and I wanted to also just go away for
college and yeah get out from my friends
stay for tea really so what's the
Northwestern and it was interesting is
uh I've always had this passion you know
one of the reasons I'm in marketing is
I'm just really interested in the
consumer psyche kind of go she was
intellectually and then also just on how
people connect and I've always just been
interested in creative as you said kind
of wired a little bit differently and so
looking at that I got really into
marketing I'm also been really into
sports and so that's where I'll get into
my background in sports marketing but
when I was in college
if the ironic thing is at Northwestern
is the school that is esteemed from an
MBA standpoint for marketing and Kellogg
and all this kind of stuff but as an
undergrad you know the closest I could
get was like I was an econ major
right which I didn't care much about
economics but it was one of these things
that wasn't and so I wanted to really
get more experience in that space and so
I said you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
start a business I see a couple needs so
I actually started a business when I was
in college as an undergrad in
Northwestern love was called ad shop and
basically it was connecting the dots
between there was this need on campus
and this is not gonna totally but if you
go back to one of these college campuses
around the time when I was in college
you'd have papers plastered all over the
frickin Student Union for shows here
this they're taped to the ground you
know it's a size it's very the marketing
for student groups sucked yeah basically
at the same time you have people who are
interested in marketing and getting into
advertising marketing and people want to
say well what's your portfolio what have
you worked on yep connecting those two
dots together saying huh there's
probably some people here who want to
like get their feet wet there's also a
need to kind of do be more effective in
targeting so we started this thing as
kind of the first
advertising agency for student groups on
campus and the thing just blew up it
started growing by the end you know by
the time I graduated I had a number of
people in this organization when written
up by the Chicago sun-times we have
clients and local at is it well they
became a thing and so that and then
Siddhanta so we passed it on and they
became a thing and then and then
separately you know and saying like I'm
kind of getting interested this idea
just you know leading and being an
entrepreneur so my senior year I did
kind of a more of a for-profit you know
kind of one that was this thing or the
campus pipeline was about kind of
targeting college students with
advertising with local businesses things
like that so definitely I need it on top
of the original idea yeah just to kind
of take as that kind of a spin off sort
of thing and so but it also gave me a
lot of experience and just kind of you
know leading big teams I've always been
kind of very involved even again in high
school leading big groups all that kind
of stuff and so as you think of some of
those things formatively
and then also just as I think of the
type of experiences that led to my
career you know when I was a junior I
interned at the u.s. Olympic Committee
you know as sports marketing was kind of
my passion and so I was a very your life
what did you think you were gonna do
you're gonna run marketing for the
Lakers like you had a night it was more
a matter of yeah like I knew sports was
something else passion about marketing I
really started to really hone and all
that and I'm like and then this was
again like the not to date me but like
the Internet the the way that the job
site saw this at like it wasn't as as
easily accessible Durr than you I know
thanks to like me so don't worry I think
it's but so literally and it's funny if
you were asked my college roommate II
would like oh it's tease me about this
but like my senior year I sent out about
300 like resumes the article that was a
sort of I sent out to every sports team
agency this kind of sponsor and we're
sitting like castanets see what's our
proactively wide net I'd like that and
then I got doesn't believe in the most
horrible really I'm sorry Nick but no
but I got I mean I got a ton of you know
interest in offers and as we were kind
of going through it and it was just a
really good experience and so I ended up
getting other cell so you remember some
of the offers so there was a variety you
know we were talking
and you know is Evan from IMG all the
way to the you know every sports team
and a lot of the coming out of college
it's like also where do you want to move
where you want to live yeah going back
to my SoCal story like I was freezing my
ass off done with this expire I have to
get back to California yeah and so one
of the really interesting ones that came
up was a sports marketing agency that
was in in the Bay Area where is called
Mill sport at the time and Visa
International was there their clients
and so it was basically the lead visas
Olympic Games and all their global
sponsorships so moved back to California
after undergrad lives in the Bay Area
when units this is two times class of
2000 so you thought you were going to
the paved streets of gold a little bit
yeah right so let me was a crazy it was
was it April 2000 what a melted was the
April 2001 I always try to remember do
you remember you graduated in that class
of 2000 yeah already it was just after
cuz I April 2000 you know a lot of these
comms a lot as people were reaching out
at the time similarly sports comm were
40 trillions this is that that as long
as it the the pets.com side and so on so
literally like so so as you're kind of
on your way to graduation the world is
unbelievably fraught I'm like oh it's
like right now well it's like yeah I'm
thinking like dude we're gonna go get
this thing and also at less mm calm
bubble bursts yeah you know go to the
book bake so you go to the Bay Area
right as everyone's like
frowning - it's kind of like yeah what's
going on out here and then I'm and yes I
started with with visa working for no
support but I worked in house in visas
headquarters down in faust Katya does
that make sense it was really cool
getting exposure so doing everything
from
working on you know worked on the Sidney
Salt Lake Olympics and the Athens
Olympics were the main ones kind of you
know getting ready that we did and did
everything from managing a huge on-site
thing in Athens with all the former
Olympians called the visa Olympian
reunion center all the way to just you
know the comms and everything in between
and just it was
a great experience because also for that
stage in my career being straight out of
college the team there was very senior
level and getting exposure also in a
global business because it was a global
sponsor she also worked on like Rugby
World Cup the things that we're going on
in Australia New Zealand it was really
great learning ground
real cliche there can be like what the
hell's rugby and it was a really cool
experience just kind of getting exposure
to that and so did that for a number of
years out in the bay area and then
straight after the athens 2004 olympics
came out east to business school which
is where I went to Yale and then between
my first and second year is where I
discovered Pepsi actually Indra Nooyi
are our former CEO was speaking on
campus and I was like kind of the again
the the dorky guy went up to Edwards and
said hey you guys recruit and I didn't
let's put my dorky guy you know I know
that that's what I'm tripping in on it
you said it you know I view it a little
bit different based on the stories and
something I think a lot about I said it
yesterday like somewhere I don't
remember if you don't ask you don't get
you know you send out these 300 things
you go up to Indra like I'm also I'm
also yeah I'm also a person who can want
like who lives in a world where I can
see in people's eyes they want to come
up and do something and they don't and
because others do I can't get to that
person and Andy rocks like we're gonna
miss our flight and we run away and and
I think about those moments a lot I'm
like wow that person really wanted to
ask something they might have you know
99% of time they're not necessarily
saying something I need or I'm
interested in or you know but the amount
I mean the Iraqi many times the vrock
saw me speak at Columbia right thought
it was interesting and emailed me eight
times before I answered right and now is
you know the South of France listen I a
lot of times when I'm doing this like
obviously I love having you on a show
but I'm desperately worried about
everybody listening right now another
it's a second example and I just feel
like people need to act you need
like if you ask respectfully like if
you're the one you know listen to rock
emailed eight times there's people who
like inappropriately stand outside my
office and do other things that's not
gonna work if you're making the person
uncomfortable if you're not bringing
them value but if you respectfully ask
yeah you're putting yourself in a
position so Indra at Yale you hear that
and and you were impressed by her word
or Pepsi was so iconic or I don't want
to make sure the boat yeah one of the
reasons I went back to business school
frankly was when I was in sports
marketing I knew that there would be
probably a cap to kind of where I could
go what I could do you got a taste of
the landscape at that point world so if
I don't give an MBA I'm not gonna be
able to yeah and it was it was less than
you know in an NBA you know the advice I
give whenever anybody asks me about hey
should I go back and get my MBA I do it
I always say listen you go to law school
your lawyer go to med school your doctor
you go to NBA you're a dude with an MBA
okay and so at the end of the day when
you think about Business School it's not
about having the NBA that actually does
anything for you it's what you do with
it it's how you broaden your horizons
it's the networking it's all the kind of
stuff that comes with it and so that to
me going back to get it
back to my story was about broadening my
horizon beyond kind of this world of
sports yeah I'm learning more about you
know the financial stuff and market and
all the place like Yale you into all
sorts of people speakers and that's
different and so again when I was there
it was less even about I'd go to class
and do all this stuff but I was there
for the whole experience and so when you
talk about going to a place like Yale
where as fortunate enough to go and
they're the speaker's the people it
wasn't out of control and so going all
these things and I would make the most
of just to your point of just go to all
the attend all these speakers go to all
these things I'd go I let a trip to
Japan with a group of my friends that
are aware that people helped we
connected but the head of Nissan and all
this stuff I mean like it's the actors
the brand it was what it was a very it
was a very you know I believe basketball
is always a fun competitive like League
as well right right so so that was
really cool there and ended up I ended
up interning for Pepsi in between my
first and second years and the irony was
I had wanted to get go to Pepsi or a big
CPG to kind of get beyond sports market
just broaden my horizon and guess where
they placed me for my interest in sports
or screwed a guy named um I got away
who is was an iconic time and was kind
of one of my mentors who brought me into
Pepsi and we you know got along like you
know two peas in the pod and just made
the most and so it came back full-time
and you know what's funny about that
story just for everybody a lot of the
things that I tell my brother AJ I have
a sports agency and a lot of the things
I tell kids before the draft is you know
they're like I want to go second round I
want to go third round like bro I'd
rather you go
fifth round than second round and and
have the person ahead of you in a depth
chart be the kind of veteran who
actually wants you to succeed yeah then
you going second round and having a guy
in the depth chart who is worried about
you and there's undermining you and it's
teaching you nothing or your bad
coaching like what you know it's
unbelievable how much that matters ya
know and that's what you had in this
internship
it totally is that a great kind of
mentor that uh you know definitely
looked out for now so I will tell you
the intern program at Pepsi it's kind of
a bait they do this thing every year
called the intern batch which it was
like honey you know they make the
interns that you know have a lot of fun
and do silly things and I'm still
convinced back to air they have taken
the initiative you know I'm someone who
likes to put myself out there so when I
was the intern this year they had a way
to do a 1980s fashion show for the
entire for the entire company out of
outside and purchase right and so
everybody you know someone's dressing up
like Madonna's dressing up like you know
Miami Vice I decided a good idea to do
Tom Cruise and risky business basically
Heidi whities white shirt you want that
thick you went there and did I I went
there and quite literally I still get
asked by people about I'm convinced
that's the only reason I got hired I
believe that I believe I'm literally
just put yourself out there's like you
know a great time literally somebody
that worked at Vayner for ten years
who's now my partner in empathy wines
Nate single Hanley got his job because
he's SuperDuper duper tried hard during
volleyball as an intern in Vermont when
we did a company off-site yeah the way
he tried to win is why I like advanced
his career yeah I believe in that [ __ ]
that's exactly right that's but it has
to be authentic to you right that's that
you're that kind of character
yeah I'm assigned like hands or some
sake that's right but that's what I'm
saying like - everybody's listening
right now if you like okay like I'm an
internship right now I'm gonna break
out this year no not you're super
introverted it's going to come across a
super awkward it all that history is
like the core of all this stuff and to
that point you know I you know to the
point and we can get to kind of core
skills and all this stuff but I I do a
course at PepsiCo on on storytelling I'm
a big proponent of yes so where he's
having and how to tell a good logical
story and all this stuff but uh that's
one of the big myths no MERS is
everybody feels that you know to tell an
effective story to present it a big
conference yeah do anything you gotta be
somebody who yeah the key is be yourself
hundred hundred percent authentic to you
and just own it you know don't try to be
what you're not and just I'm sure right
now to leave you know what to make this
point I'm sure for you and I we share a
lot of this you know charisma over to
that like there's a lot of times where
we knowingly know some of our energy is
detrimental given the contact stuttering
and you try to tone it down but even
that is not going to necessarily be who
you are either totally I mean there's
places we're onstage it's great that I'm
like cursing whatever but I'm you know
in small meetings sometimes like that
it's just like that's not gonna play
yeah but I'm still gonna do it because
that just like most comfortable anyway
yeah I'm fascinated by challenger brand
being a number you know you are not you
know some of the stuff that you're
getting heralded for in the last couple
hours here announced some of the coolest
stuff like this the Pepsi challenge is
one of those iconic things of all time
like nobody listening right now is
confused that Coke Pepsi is like some of
the most interesting banter in business
yeah there's not that many places where
you have such a dominant one and to that
it's almost fun to watch Ali and Frazier
fight yeah but you happen to find
yourself in that world how is that how
do you think about that yeah have you
when you're talking to predecessors that
have run the business have you leaned
more into I'm gonna punch you in the
face have others been more passive have
you been more aggressive or vice versa
when you when you kind of got signed up
for the gig
moving like what was your initial
thoughts versus yeah yeah look I'd love
to get a State of the Union of all yes I
know totally because it's interesting
coming into this role on Pepsi from my
previous row which was again also very
entrepreneurial starting new brands on
water
yes that's or coming from that
environment into
the mothership yeah this is the name of
our allies lots of when you're feeding
it back we have you're innovating on
water people are curious but not
watching every sneeze and cursing every
tea you go to blue can jump in the
picture for everybody listening yeah
there by the way for everybody listening
as an innovator on Vayner side I always
tend to like to work on things that are
a little more under the radar cuz to be
far more creative work we tend to push
the envelope in general as a business
model you get on something like this
everybody's got an opinion
everybody's watching right and a lot of
marketing is subjective before the
reality kicks in of the results of the
business so you deal with a lot of
chatter it's almost like it's almost
like being an NBA player and I'm Stephen
a and Christmas art and everybody else
watching and listening and commenting
it's a two cents machine it is no
totally and that's and that's one of the
biggest things is you got to work out in
public a lot more than kind of you know
you can kind of yes just you know do
your thing on these other brands a
little bit more but I'd say from a
business challenge you know it's a
completely different thing on one end
you're coming into this iconic brand
that is you know got this great heritage
and pop culture music from Britney
Spears the Super Bowls I could rule
that's all that stuff right and it's got
such a great heritage at the same time
the current landscape around the
consumer world has changed and and the
consumption of the category has evolved
and all of that stuff and I'd say you
know the problem to solve as I quickly
assess it was it's not Pepsi doesn't
have an awareness issue there's a trial
issue it has relevance is what we really
needed to focus on and really that's
where I really hunkered in really
quickly of saying you know the main
thing we got to get is this brand needs
to be culturally relevant at the end of
the day this brands been at its best
when it's the those kind of things that
we talked about but in fact as I
apologize is that the kind of stuff that
and I thought this was a very smart
strategy I and we didn't work on this
for context as we do digital stuff
that's more the TV stuff but everybody
who listens knows how much I'm obsessed
with Super Bowl yeah it is that the kind
of stuff that leads to having car D yes
yes so let me so give some context on
that and so one of the things I wanted
to really address is this idea
a challenger mindset yeah challenger I
think one of the things that one of the
misnomers is people think challenger
just means oh well you're number two or
whatever like that's challenged
that's not challenger right um the idea
of being a challenger is a mindset and a
mental approach to kind of disrupt think
of things a little bit differently in an
industry take him flipping on his head
and be a little bit more unapologetic
and what more confident in kind of your
approach and how you do this and so
she's one second to add a little color
commentary all fine and dandy for a lot
of us listening when your business is
tiny and you're an entrepreneur and you
don't have a board and you know you can
get there having a challenger mindset
when you have a brand the size of Pepsi
which is probably bigger than 99% of the
other consumer brands in the world a
little bit more tricky
ya know definitely a little bit more
tricky and so one of the first kind of
things as being a challenger brand is
you really got to acknowledge your place
in the world and have a kind of a
healthy self awareness for your brand
and you know I you know just even
culturally we could talk about you know
cultural that which I'm a culture junkie
as well but um I don't like things that
feel like advertising right that's like
very you know this idea of brands coming
out with brand messages I'm speaking to
you as a brand whatever without any
cultural acknowledgement of my place in
the world things I care about whatever
that is and so starting from the
standpoint of Pepsi has had this one of
our most frequent consumer interactions
that were most famous for is probably
not our most proudest moment and it's
the situation when you go into a
restaurant that for Pepsi's somebody
orders a coke and quite literally the
surfer apologizes for serving a Pepsi
okay Pepsi okay how horrible is that
that is what I mean great and every
single one of us have gone through that
experience you have sometimes we've been
there you've ordered one thing someone
the friend is ordered at all that kind
of stuff and so it's like okay and and
if you look online there's I mean main
cultures have yeah yes people say Pepsi
okay is monopoly money okay you know and
there's all these you know me I'm Kevin
Hart and okay and so saying what if what
if we took that insight because it is
super relatable who hasn't been in a
situation where they can connect the
dots of that own it and say yeah that's
how people see us but then
have some fun with it it's Pepsi yeah
and it's more than okay and have fun
with it but then do it in a Pepsi way
which again bringing the pop culture
nature so again cardi B yep okay right
you get Little John okay right and then
Steve Carrell and you have this
wonderful kind of dynamic where we're
just like now we're now we're getting
somewhere there's a fun little way you
can get the Super Bowl in this which we
should also talk about I'm a huge
believer in the Super Bowl is a is a
great platform to go bigger and broader
and all that stuff and so that's that
was kind of the genesis of that whole
concept that we really think you know it
really helped kind of reframe the
discussion for Pepsi around this
Challenger mindset and put us on the map
combined with that then this past year
the Super Bowl you know where it took
place in Atlanta which was like a gift
from the gods
of course our competitor yes Atlanta and
it's not just because like Oh company to
company and we're gonna have a little
corporate thing culturally in Atlanta
coke like runs in the veins of people
like it is like a emotion out of the
faucet it is literally a deep-rooted
thing and so saying okay we normally go
into one market I didn't say it like
that okay I was just okay we're gonna go
into a Super Bowl market typically you
know where they respond to the NFL we go
into Super Bowl we be in our chests a
official sponsor of the Super Bowl I'm
like we can't just like run the same
play we got to have a little little fun
with this and so to say okay if there's
Pepsi signs all over Atlanta these
Atlanta folks are gonna be like what the
hell's going on and so what we ended up
doing is leaning into that cultural
inside and saying we we bought out of
home over the entire city and so we had
builders that said Pepsi in Atlanta how
refreshing hey Atlanta thanks for
hosting we'll bring the drinks you know
and had a lot of fun with these very
Pepsi centric forward things that quite
literally just putting up the outer home
alone generated hundreds of millions of
earned media impressions people writing
stories people were tweeting like what
the hell I feel like I'm getting invaded
right now you know and at the time you
know even who was about to be in the
Superbowl all the people in Atlanta they
thought the Saints were coming in they
don't know like what the hell was going
on here
Pepsi in Atlanta and they got a lot of
interesting buzz and so seeing all that
a couple weeks before the Superbowl and
all the traction that was getting we're
like alright well
make sure people know we're not being
mean-spirited we all did it on the
up-and-up it means whatever and so we're
like we gotta let everybody know that
hey we're we're grateful for you to host
the Super Bowl and so we came up with
this concept called the Cola truce and
it was a it's a pretty fun also kind of
instigated Challenger thing we ended up
doing we're especially for anyone who's
been to Atlanta the world of coke is
this iconic kind of you know landmark
they have it's a Museum of all the
things and they host big events and
whatever and right out in front of the
world of coke is a statue of their fan
their founder John Pemberton he's
holding out a glass of coke greeting you
as you walk in you know sharing a coke
with the world and and all that great
stuff and so quite literally we said
what if we created a statue of our
founder Caleb Bradham and we got them to
you know have a nice little cheers
moment and celebrate and declare a Cola
truce
wouldn't that be a cool thing and so
what we ended up doing is we we built
this statue in record time by the way
cuz this was just a couple weeks out of
the Superbowl and it was just a mad dash
to even get this thing done and and we
said but rather than just do it we're
gonna engage them we've never even so
she's back to social media we never
engaged real coke on social media I know
like that's commonplace for brands yet
when he's looking his breath so we said
hey coke you know we'd love to we
tweeted a picture we think we should get
together you know whatever and coke coke
I just launched this campaign called
together as beautiful all about unity
togetherness and I'm like this is
perfect it's a movie meanwhile in
Atlanta headquarters we're gonna do
together as beautiful as it is beautiful
piece on yet we're all coming together
unlike perfect we believe together is
beautiful too why don't we come hang out
and we show them this picture of the
glass and coke tweets us back and says
of course welcome to Atlanta together as
beautiful then we tweet them back with a
picture of the full statue in the back
of a Pepsi truck saying like cool we're
on our way we don't hear anything back
yeah and then what we ended up doing is
we go there to the world of coke we
documented this whole thing and we
walked in and and quite literally we
said hey coke just invited us over here
we a lot you know can we get this you
know that we're trying to
Clara colas and they absolutely kicked
us up they're like you can't be here we
were told instructed not to let you on
the property but like okay okay we we
anticipated this and so earlier that
morning we had snuck in actually
ourselves and so you know for the ten
minutes we could get in there get the
photos or whatever and so what we ended
up doing is we tweeted the photo anyhow
and said hey we stopped by look like you
guys weren't that into it doesn't feel
very together as beautiful it's okay we
stopped by earlier this morning and then
we actually flipped it and say hey you
know we want to declare a Cola truce for
the day
anybody who tweets the hashtag Cola
truce and a picture of them cheering a
Coke and a Pepsi online we're going to
donate a meal to the city of Atlanta to
people in need - all again this is all
about being gracious to our hosts and
said hey Atlanta we get you we want to
do that good for you and so really the
thing instantly trending took off like a
wildfire got a ton of buzz earned media
social and and was really really fun and
exciting and people were tweeting
pictures of them cheering people making
dance routines up you know it's just
became a whole thing and so all that
together with the Pepsi okay with the
arrow home just was a really fun just
kind of reenergize out of the brand you
know just any one of our biggest moments
the Superbowl so as a human we're what
apps what cult-like nepto could be about
netflix social this is Todd the man
forget about the executive Netflix
social media like what what are your
consumptions right now knowing that you
love culture yeah actually we're
wrapping up here and so we'll have to do
a part two at some point about like
culture hacking and what's happening it
in on it for sure but for you as a man
like what Instagram snap you know what
Netflix shows do you watch if any yeah
Netflix is it's funny we I haven't
gotten as into kind of like the full-on
binging cuz that right now why nearly
Amazon Prime anything were you just like
when you get home you watch sports
I typically watch a lot of live sports
yeah they get a lot of ESPN I don't know
either I definitely will will dig around
on Netflix but I'm not I haven't been as
are you documentary guy I can get into
some of that sand down again stand up I
definitely like a good stand up every
now and again movies i watch a lot of
movies
about socialized Instagram Facebook
Twitter socialize you know I think I
think Twitter I think Facebook Instagram
all that kind of the standard kind of
things I'm I'm interested in I'd say but
I'm not as active you know yeah me and
it's interesting like I'm I'm not as
much of a live in public kind of persona
yeah you know just you know and all that
kind of stuff but I definitely it's
funny I consume a lot of them yeah but
I'm not necessarily out there you know
so I consume a lot of Instagram but I
actually you don't post you know what's
funny
I don't know if you know this you know I
don't share any of my family stuff at
all yeah and and and both of my main
careers both wine and now marketing
social media yeah I'm come I know this
because I know myself obviously I I
never drink beer or alcohol in college
or high school and had I not had a
family wine business I don't know if
I've ever would have drank alcohol my
life I mean if you go through high
school in college not drinking it it's
not in your culture you know and
obviously I was born in the Soviet Union
everybody was dying for vodka so my mom
like really demonized alcohol and then
social like I'm pretty I get it I'm
pretty commenced that I wouldn't
currently would be if I was in doing
something else in my life would not be I
would consume yeah but I would not post
which probably sounds funny but if you
look at the content I put out it's my
business life it has nothing to do with
my life I just think it's such a
fascinating given going back to studying
the human psyche and what I like you
know we have friends and people we know
and yes they post everything they're
eating everything whatever my kid won a
baseball game all the way up to
everything yep and at the end of the day
like and that's all good and fun yeah
that's what a lot of it's for for me you
know I'm you know I'll post I'm like hey
happy birthday
or whatever but I'm not as I am thrilled
they post cuz the one thing that clearly
we share is I got to listen a little bit
more is I want to know why they're
putting up the video of their kids
scoring a touchdown I want to know why
they're sharing you know their their
Disney made all of that that's how I
basically come up with all my ideas
totally well in that there's a just so
much rich insight into kind of the the
human behavior of why and how people are
sharing all these things even back to
this summer campaign we just launched
with Instagram right some yeah in which
you know about yep where we've created
250 AR filters you know and they're all
tiles the core inside of it I mean
Instagram is probably the epitome of
this kind of like look how great my life
is out of behavior where everyone's seen
that iconic photo of their feet on a
lounge chair by the paint the rows a
next year side right and then Rosalee
right I got to get that in there job and
really capitalizing it saying yeah well
if Paulo Jetta Klee how do you kind of
you know amplify what these AR effects
and stuff but it's so there's just so
many little nuggets like that just even
just looking around mining on social
media to really let's wrap up one thing
i like watching your Team Dynamics
you know I do see you know the the
entrepreneurial spirit like I have this
quite a bit as a leader as well which
you get a lot of the motivation the
rah-rah the the fire the thing the other
thing you get with characters like us is
sometimes we're moving so fast there's
collateral damage as a leader you know
and and I think what I bought because I
love watching yeah what I've watched is
I think you have a similar dynamic than
I do which is you know obviously when
you're in the lead position there your
team is always gonna have to be a deal
with the reality of like okay that's our
leader like we're gonna have to deal
with that but but I think it's palpable
on your team as it is with mine yeah how
do you think about having an
entrepreneurial spirit in a corporate
environment where inevitably a lot of
people that work for you are a little
bit more structured and every T&I is
crossed you know speed is sometimes the
enemy and they I think you and I
probably put speed on a pedestal there's
other people sometimes misinterpreted as
being sloppy yeah but I think we look we
counter with like but we focus on what
actually matters early you know how's
that that yeah yeah it's it's tricky
because I think like you I care deeply
about team I do a lot of off-site steam
building you know self-discovery stuff
and we go do all this crazy stuff and
really want to form a bond to really
make sure we have a shared vision I
think the first step is making sure
everyone is subscribed to like what
we're trying to do do you get why do you
get where we're going
are you bought in and how do you feel
like you actually can contribute and
connect this and build upon this so
that's one thing that I think is parama
- is it all starts with trust as a team
its I'm making sure all so people
understand each other you know the other
thing I talk about is you know a lot of
people I wanted want to feel comfort
bringing them whole selves to work right
and you're connecting as real people not
just as work people that's right and so
I think making sure we kind of break
down some of those barriers and build
the trust to get to this idea of
high-performing team I think once you
get that go and then you have a good
shot to really do whatever any do I
think the question is is in a big
corporate environment like PepsiCo to
your point folks like me and you were
where - boom boom boom we're moving
quick we're thinking we're spitballing
ideas throwing stuff out sometimes again
it's it's a trained muscle you know
sometimes you got to break a few eggs to
kind of make some omelets right and get
it going and so every now and then
there's some times we're like hey go go
go and that's like oh we can't do that
because legal said this oh we can't do
that because of this and it's like and
I'm trying to instill hey I don't need
all those things to always boil up to me
to help kind of Duke it out with our
some cross-functional teams or figure
out what we can and can't don't either
three four ten is the Hall of Fame
that's that's exactly three hundred
right now junior Eddie Murray total
these iconic Oriole players top what uh
what uh what uh what do we want to uh
and with what like for everybody who's
listening we have a you have a slew of
different psychographics on my show you
have a ton of young aspiring but and an
awful lot of people more in our age
group that yeah that I do think wish
their DNA was a little fast a little
more spontaneous like anything anything
kind of last parting shot for people
that are trying to get into a happier
place or I trying to accomplish more
yeah and I think I wouldn't even connect
it to any of this stuff on on Pepsi
anything like that but I would I would
say is kind of more what we were talking
about earlier is that if you it's kind
of life is what you make of it which I
know is the most cliche kind of thing
out there but it's this idea I tell
everybody at Pepsi I meant for a lot of
younger folks and people who are just
coming in and a lot of people see see
the world as it's presented to them not
as it is right so they'll get a job and
say well my job description says
whatever and I'm like every job I've
been in at Pepsi I've kind of not not
written completely but you make it your
own what is your take on it what are you
gonna bring to this then what are you
passionate about is you connect the dots
don't always ask them just say you know
here's the things that you need to do
here boom boom boom boom boom like what
can you do to kind of make your job your
own it's kind of like it's kind of like
brand marketing right all every brands
big brands you know sentence or mission
statement is so vague without how you
interpret going for it or doing it for
one time yeah life beyond the life or
whatever it might be totally yeah that's
complete interpretation when it's I mean
case in point when I when I came into
the water business right it was like hey
we sell Aquafina we gotta play we got
the segmentation done by about it and I
was looking at and I'm like it feels
like but I'm looking outside and seeing
explosion of premium water I'm seeing
I'm like this this doesn't feel right I
mean maybe we should take a step back
and rethink it and so in a second like
if I'm leading water so let's turn it on
its head let's come up with a new thing
let's come up with some new brick and so
it's like don't be afraid to push or
question the norms just because they're
presented to you like see the world as
it is not how it's presented to you and
deal with the ramifications and with
that right which is like and if you
sucked and you innovated crappy water
and you got fired what you can always go
do something like honestly look at some
level like one of the biggest ways I
think that I've been able to help my
friends and then employees like do
things yeah
is just push them very heavily on what
what will happen yeah you'll get fired
okay well that sucks and that's bad do
you have any savings yeah you know and
sometimes a person's like yes I'm like
you know I'll really go into it like I'm
like wait you have three doors worth of
savings oh no and you're not trying to
push the envelope you can get fired and
chill free your and still be okay other
people are in debt and they can't
maybe you can't push as hard but while
you've decided to push in your
organization you're interviewing
outwardly just the case you do get fined
like what what right what's this idea
and it's is it almost goes back to you
know when I was playing tennis growing
up as a competitive tennis what my dad
used to always say cuz I would be a
headcase sometimes play to win
don't play not to lose and I would get
into this defensive mode well that's
what tennis is I think I believe in the
classic I'm on five one and I would lose
seven five they'd really be like I
wouldn't be thinking I'd be having food
think big shout out to nature odor on my
team who's who's led me five to three
times and it's lost seven five all three
times but that's but that's but that's
the deal it's kind of like right when
you start realizing like [ __ ] I'm
killing this guy right now I'm going I
got this and then I get in my head and
I'm like don't mess it up and mess it up
and then I change my stress start the
whole team's pushing me we got a run but
I gotta tell you no no you know but
that's totally theirs they need to be
sorry because I gotta say this there's
something crazy about tennis out of all
the like right out of all the places on
earth that I've navigated my life
it's the only place where I can get
defensive there's something crazy
about being up 5-1 and losing that
second game starting to like visualize
to come back totally and five three
comes now you're serving up 5-3 you
should cruise into this coat god forbid
you lose that game it's 5-4 it's
definitely not fine I've decided against
the five four you lost and this is total
like you react like you there's
something about so real
not even ping-pong not even other places
something about that six the mental and
the weapons of play to win not not to
lose thanks for being the show hey
thanks to you thank you everybody let's
think gold continue with this see you
you